okay
hopefully this will start
broadcasting
fingers crossed and if we're very
very lucky i won't accidentally stream
nothing after the stream's over
thank you miss wicked wolf i appreciate
that
very very much
i'm getting wooz looks to me
like i'm coming through all right
oh i see we're talking about piers
morgan yeah
i heard about that that was
beautiful that was beautiful
thank you freddy thank you very much
so um i am just flat out celebrating
this time i'll even drop the pretense
uh pink moscato water
that's a good start i think it's
chilled and everything oh nice to see
you too black cover
i i rock
not sure that's true but i'll take it
i'm happy i finally got diagnosed with
high functioning autism so yay
honestly and like here's the thing
anyone who's never been diagnosed
with any kind of um neuroatypical
or neurodivergent situation going on in
their head
doesn't understand what a relief it is
to realize there's a name for what the
hell's going on and there are
there are now tr either treatments or
methods or techniques
that can be taught to you to cope with
it and you're not just
bonkers in a way that like nobody can
help
a diagnosis is oddly enough a beautiful
thing
so congratulations as weird as that
probably sounds to a lot of people
the fun has yes yes
and it is very tasty fun indeed
i hope i'm coming through okay now now
that i've decided that this is my setup
uh for live streams and i'm bothering to
have this freaking thing
uh stick in my face i hope i'm coming
through nice and cleanly as a result of
that thank you rebecca
thank you very much um and as people um
uh if you came in earlier you would have
noticed
uh maybe some alerts that uh youtube
memberships
are now turned on and a thing uh they
don't
replace patreon it is simply an
alternative and additional however you
want to handle it but
i kind of felt like i was leaving money
on the table by not having them
turned on so i kind of finally got off
my butt
and got that going i honestly didn't
think he would go oh piers morgan again
because
he unfortunately was a reason most
people watched good morning britain
so him going would probably affect that
i'm sure it will
it's still for the better for everybody
involved
uh oh ms wiggy wolf's getting buffering
anybody else
nobody else is saying yet so i'm gonna
maybe hit refresh
i've been diagnosed with adhd joined the
club uh
listening to you talk about it sounded
familiar to me so i got it checked out
thanks
you're welcome that is a thing don't
self-diagnose um a neurodivergent
condition um because like i i do get
i do get nervous sometimes like
occasionally when i've done adhd content
on tick tock
some people have replied like that's me
but
but i don't have a diagnosis and i worry
that they're gonna start to think they
do without consulting anybody first
because some of the symptoms of adhd
can also appear in other um conditions
so you know it's very important
especially when it comes to
neurodivergency don't
self-diagnose get an informed opinion
so that you know what you're dealing
with
uh can february march
oh for goodness sake i'm so happy that
megan and harry are speaking out about
the mistreatment i
i have to confess that i haven't um
watched the interview and i haven't like
read a bunch of the breakdowns because i
haven't i've really been in the
headspace for it and
while i i'm not gonna say it's
unimportant because certainly
um in the case of someone like meghan
markle you know
she simply because of who she fell in
love with in marriage she has gone under
a preposterous amount of media scrutiny
a lot of it
very very racist and sexist and unfair
media scrutiny and i think that is
important to talk about
but at the same time this is still my
brain
compartmentalizes all this in the area
of
celebrity gossip again not to undermine
the significance of that
interview and the impression i've gotten
coming of what's come out of it
but it does mean that for me like
my brain kind of shunts that off to the
side because i don't
care about celebrity gossip and i never
have
also neurodivergent i have dyspraxia oh
i i suspect there's probably there's
probably a fair amount
in the group and probably in your
day-to-day life if you didn't already
know
i showed my friend your live stream from
last time and she said that it's
impressive that your arms look like that
oh god that's right
i flexed a muscle oh last time
oh thank you to your friend
uh there are a lot of scarily specific
things i've
entirely related to from several people
with adhd but yeah self-diagnosing is
something i avoid like the plague good
call
john i i encourage that i so want your
take on harry and megan i'm
um i mean like if i ever watch the
interview proper or like dig more into
it i won't have a take
because uh like beyond
um maybe acknowledging
something on a live stream like i'm not
gonna make a video on the topic because
the only reason i even vaguely touch on
stuff
like joss whedon gina carano um
even amber heard and johnny depp is
because it does feed into the media that
i'm talking about this is still
ostensibly
uh pop culture entertainment channel
and even though megan is an actress i
feel like that it that is too
far outside my wheelhouse
for me to be comfortable trying to
navigate that especially because it's
not the kind of thing i talk about i
mean you look at the videos i've talked
about even when i do talk about that
kind of thing
sort of thing i do it through the lens
of their creative works
or of the studios that are hiring them
and things like that and i don't have
that kind of lens
to put on this i have really no business
talking about the royal family and i
don't know enough about the culture that
surrounds that both
you know on the aristocratic level or
just the
culture of the uk and their feelings
towards the royal family like i
i'd be out of my element in about five
different ways at least
so while i may at some point either
watch the interview or read more up on
it and
have an opinion it's not something i'll
ever do a video on
if you want a new superhero to watch
after one division i suggest doom patrol
i do want to get to doom patrol
but i like i'm still catching up um
priority
one this month is to catch up on the
backlog of commissioned
books because i've started catching up
on commissioned
movies but i've got a backlog of books
that um i need i want i've got
three that i want to get finished and
have reviewed for the break room
this month and may maybe
maybe then i will
look into getting into something like um
doom patrol now at this point it's ve
it's imminently clear that i am not
keeping up with the chat
so i suppose this would be my chance to
remind
it's pinned at the top of the thing but
anyways uh super chat guarantees that i
will i will get to your question
um tagging me in it ensures that i will
see it but i might just see it
scroll past because i get on a ramble
roll
so there you go i always appreciate your
takes on media thank you
are you looking forward to falcon and
winter soldier yes i am
um i feel like the um the trailers have
done a very good job of tone setting for
that
basically affirming it being in the tone
of
like captain america winter soldier the
more espionage
ground level kind of thing and i'm i'm
here for that
last movie you watched is being turned
into a broadway musical what is the
title
what was the last movie i watched last
movie was
clue
did clue ever get adopted into a stage
show i feel like i
saw somewhere that it did i don't know
if that's related to the movie
though or like a separate thing i don't
know
most relatable grinch moment
uh depends are you forcing me to talk
about the jim carrey grinch or are we
talking
about like the real grinch i'm not even
counting the benedict cumberbatch
again congratulations i wanted to say
you're my comfort youtuber oh
that's sweet you you doubt that this is
sparkling water
what why would you question me i mean
there's obviously like
something weird going on with the
lighting there's like a tint to it i'd
like it's only showing up at the webcam
like this is crystal clear
in my hand so like i can't account for
that that's uh that's a technological
hiccup
and um i i'm not responsible for that
uh any classic who reviews coming up yet
there will be one
um later this month i need to
i don't think i've had the poll on the
patreon yet um
to decide what it's gonna be or if i did
i forgot what it was i gotta
i gotta go back and look uh i'm kind of
i'm out of
work uh mindset video idea top 10 doctor
who characters who aren't
villains it would be interesting to see
your opinion on that one i
uh here's the thing i did
i did have an idea for something kind of
like that
um but the problem was that i it started
getting
super overly specific
because like for it to be a video worth
doing
it you know if we're saying not villains
and not the doctor themselves
we also should probably not count the
companions because
that feels like its own conversation as
well and so
now we're talking about best recurring
non-companions or even best time
complain and like
some of these things i've done i've done
best one-time companion characters
um so like some of these things i've
gotten but it starts getting so overly
specific
just because of stuff i've already done
to avoid a ton of overlap
so it's not a bad idea but because of
what i've already done
and in the interest of not just redoing
those lists
it it becomes becomes messy oh
thank you kelly so kelly gingrich you
get a heart
thank you very much um and let's see
really appreciated your nuance
conversations something often lacking in
sci-fi fantasy discourse
even though there's so there's so much
to say
keep it up thank you very much i um
that i i really do try
and inject as much nuance into these
conversations as i can because
i know for me there's nothing more
frustrating
than a video on a topic
that just fails to account
for significant parts of the puzzle even
if it's a conclusion i agree or a
perspective i agree with
if i feel like they're simply ignoring
huge swaths of the context of what's
going on or
potential impacts or other elements at
play that they're just
not acknowledging i still will
disconnect because i'm like but you
you've boiled it down so far as to be
useless
that there was a fine balance to be had
between
boiling things down to have it actually
be digestible
um and without boiling down
so much that you lose
the nuance and for me it's the context
context is
king because probably the most
frustrating take for me
in general that people have um and
shows up in my own chats that people
throw at me is like
well it is always this or it should
always be this
either them saying that because this
happened in the past it should always
happen the same way
or because that happened to this person
it's supposed to be the same thing now
like
you're acting as if there's no such
thing as context you're acting as if
precedent
is the only thing that exists and that's
not
reality nothing is ever always
there always is different circumstances
that causes things to be different
i basically think of it as the um
as the chaos theory of of pop culture
discourse
every element impacts this so the more
you strip out the
the more you might potentially miss why
things are happening the way they are
um i actually am going to back up
because it was a question i saw that i
was like ooh that's an interesting
question now i can't remember what was
what it was uh top 10 murray gold scores
i actually already did that
so if you check um in my backlog it's in
there speaking of one division
i don't feel like watching it because i
just don't care about the characters of
wanda
or vision still waiting for ghost rider
no offense intended i mean
i'm not offended certainly and like to
be fair
i wasn't super invested in them as
characters either but i was really
interested in
what they would do with you know
characters that have been
kind of um underutilized up to that
point
and what they did was mostly
quite interesting oh sophia
christina botha yo
or yao yo i'm going with you and you get
a heart
thank you so much uh
if you want homemade socks give me your
measurements
i contribute i uh i can contribute with
hand-knitted goods
what measurements do you take for socks
i like i've got a tape measure to do it
but i don't
i don't know what to what
bits to actually measure uh
what is your top five stories from the
john pertwee era of doctor who
um i've still got a lot of gaps in my
per tweet so
like i i'll try and answer that but also
keep in mind
that like i'm there's a lot i still
haven't seen
but and this is going to be in no
particular order but
time warrior would be on there sea
devils would be on there
dr roon the silorians would be on there
um
trying to think if there were any others
or the ones that i've seen that i would
legitimately consider to be
top 10 worthy terror of the autons
yeah sure um
i mean i've seen more than those but
none of the others like
are i would feel top five worthy so i
feel like
i just need to watch more to figure out
what else would go on that list
would oh well first of all that is a
heart for
yoshi fan 109 now
i can't quite do the yo she knows i
tried to do it with sticking my tongue
out at the same time
would you ever do a video about your
favorite characters from the classic
doctor who tv series and from big finish
audio
yes but in both cases i need to fill in
more of my gaps
before i would be comfortable doing that
because i just know
that people more versed in those things
than i
am would just come at me with wait how
do how could you not consider this or
this it'd be stuff i hadn't even
seen or excuse me or listen to
what did you think of the one division
finale well i've got a full uh
video review up in the break room of
geeks which is my
the sister channel for this so you can
see sort of my
um my unfiltered
thoughts there because it was um
it wasn't scripted i am gonna have a
video coming out
hopefully i'll have this ready in time
for saturday um on my thoughts on the
show overall the short version is it was
very disappointing to me that it
ended in a superhero fight i found that
frustrating there were still good things
about the finale but that
that annoyed me
length okay so like
but but do you need like toe to the heel
as one measurement and then like
heal to halfway up the yeah
up to the ankle or i yeah
i you say length then i i'm like length
of what
most relatable grinch moment any grinch
why what's special about
uh jim carrey and what's wrong with
benedict cumberbatch
nothing special about jim carrey's it's
just a terrible movie and benedict
cumberbatch one was just bland
it's not even worth getting annoyed at
um
but okay see the thing is
if we're going relatable i would
probably be forced to pick something
out of jim carrey's because that grinch
is more relatable
the grinch isn't the grinch is not
actually supposed to be
all that relatable that's part of what
both the jim carrey and benedict
cumberbatch versions got wrong
so for anyone else in future looking to
make a grinch movie
keep in mind you are not supposed to
sympathize with him
beyond possibly understanding that the
noise is a little much
so if you're gonna ask me relatable then
uh probably his whole thing before the
i can't even remember what they call it
the celebration where he's gonna be the
the cheer meister and the whole
um you know coming up excuses for
for not going and the ooh ah
oh that's how i'm not going like that i
relate to that
i do doesn't make it a good movie but
whatever
apart from what the frel uh what are
your favorite podcasts at the moment
well i wouldn't list my own
uh in that anyway i am um
i'm quite fond of i'm gonna list a
couple
i enjoy uh the slightly civil war
podcast which is from the escapist i
like your brain on facts
i like the bugle i like i listen to wait
wait don't tell me
as a podcast i have started listening to
kill james bond
which that's an entertaining time so
those are kind of the big ones at the
moment like there's a bunch i listen to
that i've just fallen behind on but i
want to get back on track of
things like pixel squirt or um
um i'm i'm way behind on improvised
weapons
um i've i once once i'm caught up on
books i need to binge through that thing
um and really catch up
uh that bat what oh what batman villain
do you think would fit best in the dr
who universe
i mean i'm just gonna say
clay face just because he's the most
fantastical the most alien-like
oh sophia christina botha again
thank you f me your cleavage is bigger
than mine
well like uh to be fair
this uh this particular shirt which hold
up
beautiful valid loved official merch
link in the description for the t public
store
um this shirt really hugs
hugs the cleavage um
to the point of like really they they
honestly look
bigger in this shirt than they actually
are they are decently sized um
and i am i'm larger than my partner at
this point
but um they they do look it's because
it's
because it's got the slight stretching
effect right here that really does sort
of
um give a give a
greater impression of um
volume let's let's go with that
uh shoe size or toe to heel uh also just
follow you on twitter but under a
different username okay
um so i don't know what
like my inches toady hill would be my
shoe size
us shoe size it's 10 and a half men's or
12 women's
um yeah the gals look good yeah
good to know uh
all right so i've jumped back down i've
i've missed a whole bunch of stuff
so uh have you heard of line of duty
it's a british drama about police and
then it
[Music]
then the comment got away from me
uh police anti-corruption unit 12 would
be highly recommended
haven't heard of that one do you plan on
making any videos on torchwood in the
future
not um anytime soon torchwood
largely falls under the if somebody pays
me
um bucket because i didn't
really care for most of torchwood
aside from children of earth and even
that one it took somebody commissioning
me for me to
rewatch it and do a video on it
that said if
[Laughter]
if i ever get caught up on stuff myself
and see miracle day
and if and when i do get around to that
i will do a video on it probably in the
break room
but for now i don't really
i don't really plan what nail polish are
you wearing i am wearing
ten different well nine different colors
and
one currently uncolored nail so like i'm
all over the place
what nail polish are you wearing which
finger
um this is mostly
um
sally hansen god my brain was
scrambled trying to think of what the
heck the company was
um or uh roya
is the other one for some of these oh
blessed rain
how's it how's it going it is going
quite well thank you very much and also
connor johnson
thank you so much fargo the film turned
25 yesterday wow
i'm old i remember when that first came
out and like it was a it was a
it was a news story the fact that in the
credits of the film it says it's based
on reality and then it's like no it
isn't and people are being fooled i'm
like no it's the
it's the uh the coen brothers having a
laugh at everybody because
most people didn't know how to how to
search on the internet to confirm stuff
thomas thank you very much
any favor big finish audios oh yeah um
honestly you can't go wrong if you
listen to anything written by robert
shearman um
my top one is right now still uh
holy terror which has my favorite line
in all of doctor who and it's actually
there's a needlepoint um of it here
which is uh it doesn't matter
uh oh hang on yeah
i had it right it doesn't matter to whom
the cruelty is directed the cruelty
itself is wrong
that that line means
the world to me because so much of what
goes on in the world what people do to
each other
comes down to rationalizations
and justifications for why it's okay to
behave that way
towards that kind of person yeah this is
mean
but here's why it's okay to do it to
them
and just keeping in mind it doesn't
matter to whom the cruelty is directed
the cruelty itself is wrong
like i that that is so important to me
um but uh in addition to that uh chimes
of midnight
is great jubilee is great fear monger is
great
um deadline uh which is like an
alternate one and and um honestly pretty
much
all of um
the the war master especially sky man
oh that one's like right up there with
children of earth in terms of be
prepared
to go to a dark place oh
that one oh so
oh my goodness you people you're so
generous
thank you very much 20th century toy
congratulations on
50k i need to know what the figure in
lingerie
is between the two funkos on the top
right i can always see if i can't figure
out
how it is so okay so right
launch ah so that is
i believe arkham asylum version of
harley quinn
is uh is what that is
so um i can oh
goodness before i see the other super
chats i'll get to them in a second
somebody's got this for me off my um
off my amazon wish list and i'm not
going to take it down because it was a
pain in the butt to get into position
but you see the the yellow lump
right there that over my shoulder
that for uh the what the frel
listeners that is a plush drd
from farscape those are the little uh
the
little yellow sort of almost mouse droid
looking things with a little antenna
that
scoot around moya and do all the little
repairs
i was delighted when i found that to
even put on my amazon whistle it
am amazon your wishlist sure
need more water uh when i saw it to put
on my amazon wishlist and even more
delighted when it turned up
that ah that made me so happy all right
ben oh yes no heart only a non you're
british i understand
biggest regret
that one is always really hard
to answer because
i how do you measure that
there's certainly a lot of things from
my life
that i wish i hadn't done
or had done differently but at the same
time i'm i
can't ever i can't engage in
a thought exercise of like well what if
this never happened without my brain
immediately starting to line up
the dominoes basically the butterfly
effect results of that
yes i regret this or this
but if that hadn't happened would i be
where i am in my life right now
would i be doing this work would i have
the family i have would i be
with the partner that i have and
largely for that reason it's really hard
for me to pin something down that i feel
comfortably saying because i always feel
like the undercurrent
to saying this is your biggest regret is
you wish you could go back and change it
but ultimately
most of it i wouldn't there's certainly
a lot of stuff that i would never want
to have to go back and relive again
um because of my part in it
which you may have guessed from the
vagaries
that i've been doing this with most of
my answers are personal to the point
that i would not actually share them on
the live stream
because most of my regrets my serious
regrets
are reflective of things that happen in
personal relationships
some platonic some romantic but that's
where a lot of my
lingering regrets are and that's the
kind of stuff that i don't
share on live streams because it's not
only my story
and i try very hard to not share other
people's stories
and it's also partially a defense
mechanism if i'm being
um completely honest because there is
there is that nagging
there's that nagging voice of doubt
in the back of the head that says
if they knew all the crap that you've
pulled throughout your life
they wouldn't be here watching you
they wouldn't support you which is
probably
ridiculous but you know
it's a it's a nagging notion it's
especially ridiculous given
how much i'm not the person i was
when i did most of the stuff i regret
the most
but that's still in there that's that i
i would be lying if i said the only
reason i don't share these stories is
because there are other people involved
part of it
is self-preservation
so there you go oh kara
or cara ah cara i think
i know i know i've asked you've
specified for me before so now
now i feel embarrassed but you either
way
you get a heart um
did you notice that the government of
ireland
is in the one division credit still
haven't figured out
why also congrats on 50k i had
not noticed that
i could i can't think of why that would
be
there wouldn't have been any location
shooting in ireland
i don't think i
that's wow that is either going to be a
fact that i forget
immediately or it's going to stick in my
head and as soon as the live stream is
over i'm going to start
researching it one of the two there will
be no in between
fugitive doctor have you ever been
limited by what you were before
yes thank you john
thank you very much
uh which one time doctor who villain
would you like to see return
apart from mr finch ah that is not fair
to take away my go-to answer um
the dream lord
oh meg oh
thank you meg casaboom
underbust corseter overbust which you
which you prefer to rock these days
i haven't gotten an overbust corset yet
since having developed what i have
i need to i want to i can't afford it
right now
that's that's the kind of spending i
can't really justify at the moment
so i can't answer that yet stick a pin
in it
one of these days i will be able to
answer that i
i have like i think one or two overbus
corsets but they were they were bought
some time ago to accommodate breast
forms and i haven't tried them out yet
um i've also gained weight since then so
i'm really paranoid about trying on
corsets and finding out that
even loosening the lacing i still can't
do them up because that bums the heck
out of me when i find that out
but i do need to get some some new
corsetry
blessed rain again you get another heart
you're racking them up i think what hits
hard with children of earth
is as apparent it hits hard at least it
has for me on re-watching then again
i cried hard on raya too i haven't seen
raya yet um i
yes i think being a parent does make
that one
harsher although for me i still
um
i still feel the
the hardest hit um when i did the
re-watch
watching the children being
dragged away from
their parents
that that rang
way truer than it has any right to and
like more so
since the thing aired
are you going to watch superman and lois
it is not top of my list
because i'm still in catch-ups mode
cash app won't let me deposit money on
my card to send to your super
your super chat you got cash app i
actually don't have cash app
i suppose i should just like to have one
more way for people to throw money at me
put that on my to-do list
uh and thank you carr uh carowind for
catching that i
caught that out of the corner of my eye
thank you for um
for speaking up on that i appreciate it
good work as always
i love you know what free hearts to the
mods
much deserved um
uh renee moncayo
probably butchered the last name but you
get a heart
consider this bottas bustier or
uh or keto diet money
[Laughter]
oh decisions decisions on that one
thank you the beautiful game
there you go if you could
how would you change doctor who
um
the it's difficult to know
how to answer that because
there's nothing really that i change
about what has already happened because
what i love about doctor who is because
of its continual renewal process
through the ability to have regeneration
through the ability to have the doctor
to have adventures in any part of time
and space and if
someone chooses to you know not have him
encounter old enemies encounter nothing
but
old enemies or to have her
you know get wrapped up in big universe
spanning events or just get
tied up into a bunch of small things
that she has to deal with
the ability of the show to go anywhere
and do anything to me
means you don't have to change anything
about it
the nature of the show already allows
you to do
whatever you want to do just don't
mess with that
who would you like to play in the uh
clue musical i could see you as event
[Laughter]
oh god watching that movie again
she like she's bouncing to the music and
she stops
and her chest bounces for like another
full second after she stops moving it's
amazing um
uh true answer though to that is
wadsworth
100 oh no sir i'm merely a humble butler
what exactly do you do i buttle sir uh
love your hair color your nails vera
thank you charlie
do you pole dance i don't but it's only
because i don't have a pole to practice
on
i don't have well i suppose i do have
rooms where i could set it up but
i i would have to rearrange parts of the
house to accommodate a poll
now the fact that i know i would have to
rearrange parts of the house to
accommodate a poll
should clue you into the fact that i've
already thought about what i would have
to do to accommodate a poll
just saying
fun fact about holy terror the people
playing mother and son
are actually husband and wife oh that is
kind of fun
thoughts on ryan johnson
i hate him and that comes from luke
skywalker so
you know i i expect that uh that you
would
um but
so here's the thing i actually really
like ryan johnson as a filmmaker and
i've got it it's on my to-do list
i i will be surprised if i get to it
this year
but i want to do uh an overview
kind of of just what he does in terms of
his approach to films because
deconstruction is his entire thing
i still haven't watched brick yet i need
to see that one but
every film he's done has been a
deconstruction he has deconstructed
noir he has deconstructed time travel
he has deconstructed the khan artist
movie
he has deconstructed the murder mystery
and he's really good at deconstruction
the problem was they shouldn't have been
deconstructing
the leads and the main characters and
the core themes of star wars
in the main saga
i'm not even gonna say he shouldn't have
been deconstructing star wars but he
should have been doing it in one of the
side
projects for what he does
and what he's good at nobody should have
given him access
to luke skywalker
they just shouldn't have knowing what
the man does
that that was a bad idea because he did
what he always does
he deconstructed the heck out of it and
nobody wanted that to happen
well i say nobody there's some people
who really do like the last jedi
because of its deconstructive nature
because of its subversive nature
because it is so much what you don't
expect except that i'm also quick to
point out as much as i love a
deconstruction deconstruction itself
cannot be the end goal it's still
especially in a franchise that has to
serve a greater purpose
so when you deconstruct a primary
continuity like that
i'm not gonna be on board for that
so i really like ryan johnson
as a director i just think he shouldn't
have been put on the main saga of star
wars
doom patrol is my personal favorite
thing called danny the street yes
i've heard about danny a sentient street
that acts as a safe haven
for the social rejects in the world um
sorry i i don't know the term and
danny's non-binary
i know that too uh thank you for reading
my comment i'm looking forward to your
ryan johnson review video
yeah i have no idea when i'll get to
that that honestly that'll probably be
next year
in terms of the the pace at which i am
getting
like really heavy workload pieces out
like the last
the last um really involved video i got
out
was the was the video on the watchmen
movie
and um i don't i don't even know
when i'm gonna get to another one of
that scope i want to
but again i've got i've got too much
other stuff i need to i need to get
fully packed up and changed away
i'm a changed man i no longer love the
last jedi like i used to my new favorite
is revenge of the sith
interesting choice judging by the
characteristics of the character do you
think
the riddler is more sick and twisted
than the joker
i think the riddler is more
self-destructive
than the joker um whether or not he is
more
sick and twisted depends on specific um
interpretations you could certainly do
him that way
but i think by and large he's just way
more
um self-sabotaging
than the joker because the joker has
little rhyme or reason
and his rhyme or reason changes even
when he does have it
the riddler can't stop himself
from laying out clues if he
truly wanted to get away with stuff he
would just
stop doing riddles and he could probably
get away with most of what he does
but he can't stop himself from doing it
uh what are your thoughts on it's a sin
i've got a whole review video up go
check that out once the live stream's
over
excuse me
too bad you don't have polish ancestry
then you could be a pole on a pole
oh i love terrible wordplay
and that was that was terrible
would you consider reviewing ryan the
last dragon
i mean i'll see it eventually whether or
not i get to it quickly is actually
going to depend i need to find out
whether or not
um because i'll i'll have i'll have my
kid this weekend
i need to find out whether or not she's
already seen it if she hasn't i will
rent it if she has
i'm not sure i'm going to shell out 30
bucks just for me to see it especially
considering i don't think i'll make that
much back in the
for the views i get on a review i if i
was going to do that i needed to have
gotten the review out
last week so
what is your second favorite doctor who
episode
um
you do realize every time i answer that
i'm gonna give a different answer
uh
let's go with midnight
could you see david tennant playing the
writer the ritter
[Music]
the riddler oh yeah sure i remember
seeing mocked up
um fan posters of him being the riddler
for uh for the third
uh nolan batman movie before way before
it even added a title
uh oh meg
uh have you checked out vampires on
netflix i just noticed it today
no no that has not caught my eye as yet
oh renee again thank you very
very much for the super chat uh
and this is today bona drag
omo pallone bona
takata your eek dolly that raya
i read it i don't
i hope you really did write it that
um unusually because
otherwise like i'm having a stroke
did you just make me say something
really obscene in a different language
renee what was that
what are you doing to me renee
why do you do these things to me
i can't do that dave open the pod bay
doors hal
i can't do that dave okay
[Laughter]
um what's some advice you can give
uh regarding content to a new youtuber
um pick stuff you love
the the less it feels like work the more
you'll be able to stick with it
so be sure it's something that you love
talking about and love creating content
on
more than anything because whatever
thoughts i might have about a preferred
style or editing approach or delivery
you know vocal delivery that's just my
preference
and other people prefer other things but
just
find what you love don't try and be like
anyone else you'll take inspiration
especially early on
i did but find your voice and be sure
you're talking about stuff you
want to talk about
uh
have you listened to the hamel drop
soundtrack
nope that passed me by um
let's see
i said your hair and clothes were
beautiful in
polari oh okay
well thank you thank you i'm glad
somebody clued me in on that
what are your thoughts on the 10th
doctor supposedly taking over torchwood
i mean that's going to be an audio
adventure thing so
until i listen to it i have no opinion
uh
i do something that the bbc would never
be happy with banish the doctor
from earth uh have them be able to go
anywhere but there
you're right the bbc would never let you
do that simply for budgeting reasons
i mean the the as much as i wish i
desperately wish that doctor who would
not be as earthbound
as it is ultimately the reason that
happens
is for cost reasons
it's way easier just to shoot on
existing locations or existing sets than
to build whole new alien
worlds or spaceships or what have you
it's more cost effective that's why it
happens
uh let's say what are your thoughts on
the hobbit the battle of the five armies
oh uh you mean um
the saga of thorin oakenshield
because that movie has no
business being called the hobbit
that's actually one of my earlier video
reviews you can go way back
and find my full thoughts on that it's
garbage
it's really really really really really
really really really really
really really really really
really really bad it is
so so very
very bad and it hurts me
to think about
i have spoken have you seen
amphibia well first of all tube's the
one
you get a heart the super chat and no i
haven't um i've seen it to the extent
that
when i go on um
disney plus it shows up like they're
advertising for it but no i have not
watched that
uh so are we supposed to assume that
dceu
harley quinn has the same multiple
recollections of her origin
like the joker has i mean i would say
it's actually
arguable whose perspective the origin
bits we saw in suicide squad even
were because you know that um
that thing was such a mess anyway
can you do a cross side face can i do a
cross i've i can do you one better
than cross side
there you go somebody's gonna clip that
and embarrass the hell out of me
uh
i feel like i'm always on thin ice when
i'm posting on live streams so i'm
scared
it's okay logan breathe
it'll all be okay have a drink of water
uh i'll do it yes of course you will
favorite episode of red dwarf smeg head
um
oh jeez
um i've always really gotten to kick out
a polymorph
but there are a lot of really good ones
which doctor who character you used to
like with first viewing but dislike
now um it hasn't really changed with
viewing but my opinion
of kate stewart goes down the more time
she shows up
because they haven't known how to write
her well
since the first few times she appeared
would you ever watch more inside number
nine if i had more time
in my life or if somebody paid me uh
is that an l d l menzel
you get a heart for the super chat and
let's see dl here congratulations on 50k
thank you uh is there room in the space
for specifically middle-aged avengers
commentary
menopausal marvel i'm toying with it i
mean
you're first of all you're speaking to
someone who is on the border of middle
age
i am i'm only a little over a year from
40.
uh
huh and given that fact yes i would say
absolutely there's room in the world for
that
go for it if you want to talk about it
do it
ah what are your thoughts on butt monkey
characters
i'm missing something there oh
carowind the oh the discord thank you
thank you
caroline i'm sorry i missed it earlier
you're allowed to chastise me
i don't mind
okay let's see so i need to head over to
the discord
which um as a reminder is
at this point a um
special uh a special
perk for the patreon and now
also for youtube
membership participants get access to
the discord and they get uh their
questions
answered uh or comments read on live
streams guaranteed without having to do
the super chat though some of them still
do the super chat which is really really
nice some people
really enjoy throwing me money i don't
know why but please don't stop
okay uh congratulations on 50k subs
thank you
i started following you around the time
of your 10k q a when the hat came off oh
my god
three years ago now was the first time
i let my hair down
and talked about being genderfluid on
this channel not the first time i talked
about it anywhere because the vera wild
channel is actually older than this
channel
but um oh man
some more congratulations excited for
you thank you
um question in your own mind
uh do you have recommended gateway
videos to the channel oh
okay so that's so talking about my own
channel
if i were to say like here's a selection
of videos to get an idea of
what it's like to be subscribed and to
get my videos on a regular basis i'm
probably gonna lean towards more recent
stuff um in the interest of a gateway
because obviously that's the kind of
thing that i'm producing
these days like there are some older
videos that i'm very proud of
but i feel like aren't as representative
of
either my video or editing quality or
sometimes even my delivery
but so i'd probably say
let's go with the uh gay coding
video the um
uh try to think of a good doctor who one
to go with
honestly i'd say the the hell bent the
final rant
video to get a taste of the the most
unhinged
that i'm gonna get get a sample of that
and um
i feel like i should think of one more
um i think the um
the video about problematic uh authors
where i talked about
rowling card and lovecraft
i think those were the three those are
the the three i would sample
uh favorite sean bean death uh
equilibrium
would be my preferred sean bean death um
50k get out the cakes and fireworks
water and fishnet leggings we're
partying like we are on trenzolor
ah i left my fishnets upstairs
maybe i did i mean i've got i've got the
thing framed in such a way that you
don't know if i'm wearing fishnets
i might be that'll cost you a lot in the
super chat to find that out
um
with those cows of yours you look no
younger than 30.
uh you're rocking 39 with style not
quite 39 yet but later this month yeah
i had a weird thought i want your
opinion on matthew mcconaughey as norman
osborn
huh
i kind of want to see it like sincerely
ugh i watch vivre wild videos when i
suffer from insomnia and they soothe me
so i can sleep i like it's not uh
it's not shocking for me to hear that
you go for the vera wild videos as
opposed to the council of geeks because
i can get
ranty over here i like to think it's
part of the charm
maybe you tell me but um
over on the vera wild channel i use
a softer voice
um and also it's like slightly pitched
up still
so
so when i'm over on the vera wild
channel
i'm i use more of my upper register
and i talk a bit softer and i often talk
a bit slower the thing is this isn't
really an act i was going to say it's
not an affectation
it is but it's an affectation in that
when i'm really tapping into my
femininity as directly as i can
as opposed to sort of landing wherever i
do
and even veering around all over the
place some days
when i really zero in on the feminine
sides of myself my voice tends to soften
anyways
and people may even notice during
council of geeks videos
that there are times when
i get a little bit emotional and i if
i'm not if it's not something that i'm
shouting about
then i have a tendency to
slow down and go a little bit quieter
and my speech patterns will actually
more closely resemble
what i do over on the vera wild channel
than a lot of my standard rants on this
one
so ah
so to shift shift out of that code
switch yes that is that is the term
thank you black cover uh the next doctor
who character you should cosplay as
perry from the sick the sixth doctor's
companion
nah super fan of her look gonna be
honest
uh
can you do a tour of your collection in
the back sometime
uh it would be a video love considering
how bloody awesome
it looks um yeah oh god
it is getting crowded back there
um like i did some rearranging
just a couple of days ago when the when
the drd showed up
and i i try very hard not to remove
anything i don't want to i don't want to
take anything because
nearly all of this stuff is
gifts things either given to me by
people who know me you know personally
day to day
um or have come as gifts from you folks
and i don't want to remove anything
if i can help it the only stuff that's
ever gotten removed
was harry potter related stuff i had
a harry potter figurine and i had
a um snowy owl
that was not official merch it wasn't
officially hedwig
but that's obviously what it was meant
to represent those i took down
um but the rest of this
like and even even the few that like
i got myself like the ton berry i got
myself
totoro i got myself but it would they've
totoro especially has been there so long
it would feel really weird to
take him out to make room for other
stuff
um but yeah i am legitimately
running out of space
i suppose what i can do because these
shelves are actually fairly deep
like you know
can't i don't know if you can tell but i
can reach my arm
all the way back in there so
i suppose what i could do is i could
shift some stuff
further back um but you know that would
also mean that it's
less likely to get seen by the camera
and i'm still reluctant to do that
but yeah there is um
oh yeah
man it's a lot of stuff
vera and your kiddos plush dalek oh yes
oh my god
you know it's actually
she hasn't done anything with that in
ages she might even let me have that
back um because i i had a blue plush
dalek up
for a while as carowind noted um
but it wasn't actually mine it was my
kids and she wanted it back and so
obviously it's hers i let her have it
back
but she hasn't like done anything with
it
in ages if i asked you'd probably let me
have it back at this point
because she never actually got into
doctor who she just liked the
dialect
life and fandom are weird things
my daughter doesn't really go for sci-fi
much at all
she likes dragons is what she likes
uh i'm going to go getting to 205 a.m
over here oh yeah logan get some sleep
remember to be excellent to each other
and party on
dudes uh
here's how you impersonate hercules
mulligan all you have to do is speak in
a raspy voice
and scream aggressively
[Laughter]
sexy belly flash yeah that no
you might have even like caught the
the estrogen patch when i did that
[Laughter]
uh i love in the arkham city games where
ridler vows to defeat batman and remove
his mask only if you go strange to
basically make him have a breakdown
since he already knows who he is i i
need to get back to those games i played
a few hours of the original one but the
thing is i it's been so long
since i've played third person games
that don't have a fixed
camera and it made me motion sick
because like i'm just i'm not used to it
anymore
so um that was years ago and i haven't
gone back i have it
i also have arkham city but
there it's in the pile of games i own
but haven't played
how does a writer walk the tightrope
between diversity tokenism and
appropriation
beta readers get yourself a diverse
group of beta readers
who are going to be willing to tell you
if you're doing it wrong
um because there's only so much you're
ever going to catch on your own
get other eyes on what you're doing
favorite star trek series next
generation is the only one i'm truly
nostalgic for
because i would watch
episodes of the next generation what
okay let actu let me back up
i spent summers at my grandparents
because i went to
i went to a day camp um that was just a
short walk from where they lived
and so i would spend my summers with
them and
there were a couple of shows that i
would watch with my grandfather
and so like there's a whole cluster of
things that i tend to think of as my
grandfather's shows
most of them were sitcoms like i think
of
mash and friends and seinfeld and
cheers and frasier those are my
grandfather's shows
and he wasn't really a sci-fi guy but he
did
like star trek the next generation so
when he would
put that on i would i would sit down and
watch that with him
other stuff he'd watch i kind of flit in
and out of so like
there are there are tons of tiny bits of
like
cheers and seinfeld and all this other
stuff that i've
caught and that i've seen but not a lot
of full episodes that i ever sat down to
watch
but um star trek next generation
like i
when i hear the opening credit music
to star trek the next generation i
remember
being like 10 years old
and sitting on my stomach on the floor
with my chin and my hands
watching those credits and listening to
that music
can you do an impression of eric cartman
excuse me
guys and game
yeah a little bit i haven't watched
south park in ages i think i've outgrown
it
i've outgrown the um the sort of
nihilistic approach to comedy
everything sucks and beliefs are stupid
yeah i don't
i don't really truck with that anymore
can you do a response to the to that
vegan teacher calling lgbtq plus
calling us uh selfish
um i will not do a formal response for
that because
i feel she is beneath me to spend the
time to do it
many other people are putting in a lot
of hard work to take apart
her absolute nonsense
and i am not saying that they are
wasting their time by doing so
they are choosing how to use their time
and i believe many of them who are doing
that
are using it well for my part
i will not spend my time or my
thoughts on that person
i have no reason to get invested even in
disliking her which is a very easy thing
to do
uh
rules for families in gotham if your
surname is dumpler
and you have a really obese child don't
christen that mom
i'm free
yeah what are your thoughts on the fresh
prince of bel-air i only ever watch bits
and pieces of it
here or there it's it's very
90s that's kind of all i've got
would you consider remaking the hundred
episodes of doctor who to say forever
sometime
maybe after i uh have seen more of
classic
my brother dad and i would do tng and
pizza fridays
oh that does sound nice
congrats on 50k i've been watching your
videos since 2018.
oh i am i am very glad you've stuck
around
that's see that's the thing that
kind of blows my mind it's not that
people
find my stuff it's not even that people
enjoy my stuff
is that people keep coming back for more
that's the part that i'm just like
that that's the stuff that amazes me
okay so i actually really should
uh wrap it up soon myself
um when you went up and did that
uh intimidating voice into your mic
earlier
in the stream i felt like i heard a hint
of heath ledger's joker
can you do an impression i'm getting
asked for a lot of impressions tonight
okay
hold up
do you want to know how i got these
scars
you've got a little fighting yeah i like
that
i really do think that you and i
are destined to do this forever
the thing with uh ledger's joker is it
is very
breathy it is a little bit upper
register and it is kind of
breathy and a little bit airy so
trying to think what else he's got in
there
i don't want to kill you what would i
ever do without you
go back to knocking off gangsters no
no you
complete me
uh that's a lot of fun
uh going through batman the animated
series again ronnie mcdowell is the mad
hatter
is just yeah he is they had amazing
voices on that show
they really really did talking of
impressions can you do frank and further
um i mean i'd have to just
pull some lines
oh don't be upset it was a mercy killing
he had a sort of naive charm
but no muscle
oh rocky i can't
quite do like a full-on impression i
would love to play that part give it my
own spin
but uh oh tara stuller
i thank you very much heart for you
i have an idea for 100k getting ahead of
ourselves
fireside chat with the skit pals from
your earlier vids about your origin
uh that would be
lovely and also probably
impossible
one of the two people involved that's
nicole
um who played kate
i think was the character's name um
she she moved to uh the caribbean
islands i actually forget
where now exactly but um
so she's nowhere near me anymore
um nathan
maybe i could wrangle he's a pain in the
ass to get a hold of though
because he's like he's barely ever on
social media
um like the only time i ever see him is
when i go to the farmer's market because
he's a blacksmith so he sells his wares
there
um and even if i got him to say yes
which you probably
would um but like just trying to
schedule him is a
big pain in the butt
oh excuse me riffraff impression are we
just going through impressions at this
point um
you've arrived on a rather special night
it's one of the masters affairs
which one
uh how big would that vegan teacher have
to be
to force you to respond to her
it does it's not about how big she is
she's not worth my time
i think unless she does a video
specifically naming me
which she wouldn't have a reason to do
because i sure as [ __ ] i'm not talking
about her
except here where somebody's asked
unless that happens and even if that
happened
i might not
i have no use
for feuds
i have no use for
back and forth creator call out culture
now some people probably can
and will claim that my
videos on things like joss whedon amber
heard johnny depp
janet carano is somehow call out culture
but
keep in mind the way that i approach
that the angle i take on that
is the entertainment business angle
just generally calling people out on
their bad behavior and this is not me
saying that's a thing that isn't worth
doing
but i'm just saying that's not a thing
that engages me
that's not a that's not a youtube
ecosystem that i want to be a part of
and i say that as somebody who has had
call out videos made about them from
a number of creators some very very
small
some bigger than i will probably ever be
and i've only ever not even really
responded
but addressed once
when that's happened and that was
because the person who did it was so
freaking huge that
i i had to say something because now
literally the most viewed piece of media
on youtube
that has my face on it is by somebody
else
saying bullcrap about me and implying
far worse and that's just the reality of
my being on this platform
that will always be the case that
video's got a million freaking views
that i dealt with because i felt i
legitimately had to deal with that one
because it was such a
flagrant misrepresentation of who i was
as a
person that
i that one i legitimately had to do
something about but i
don't want to deal
in that aspect of youtube i
do not want to be in
the drama feuding call out
soup i don't want to be
in that world and if i can avoid getting
pulled into it i will
i just don't want to be there
uh i am going to wrap up soon i said
that before
i probably will but
have you seen the netflix show i uh i am
not okay with this i've heard of it
haven't seen it
have you watched tennant i have not yet
i keep meaning to check if it's on
uh hbo max yet actually you know what i
need to try and
watch soon i need to watch kong skull
island i need to watch
godzilla king of the monsters because i
do want to watch
um king kong versus godzilla
when it comes out
the blair white thing was not a call out
that was slander and lies
i mean potato potato that's part of the
slippery slope that is that entire
ecosystem of youtube
uh have you ever watched dark angel nope
heard of it never watched it uh are you
ever gonna make a video on the super
straights
no that's that stuff's nonsense
been here since 2017 and the first video
i saw i disagree with and yet i
kept coming back cheers cheers to
youtube ben
and a nod
that's always my favorite i love when
people disagree with me but stick around
anyways
what are your thoughts on stan culture
here's the problem i don't actually
know like i know
um
rhetorically i know the difference
between a stan
and a fan it's a matter of degree but i
don't know
when you're talking stan culture i don't
know what differentiates stan
culture from normal fan culture and i'm
not sure i want to know
i do want to say that i find the name of
it kind of gross given where it comes
from and what that
song was actually a freaking bout
anybody who is actually going to say oh
i'm a stan
for this like like look into the origins
of that term and really think about gee
is that what you actually want to be
that's what kind of weirds me out about
it that's about the most of an opinion
i'll have
uh roddy was also one of my favorite
one-off villains from the 66 batman
series i forgot he was on that see i
mainly know
roddy mcdowell from uh the planet of the
apes movies
because he was cornelius and he
was brilliant
he was so good him and kim hunter but
ronnie mcdowell really kind of became
the face of the franchise
uh starting with the third one oh he's
so good
oh yeah i need to stop
what are your thoughts on batman vs
robin the animated movie hated it
absolutely hated it there's a review up
i am
[Music]
very far behind
um on
catching up with the dc animated stuff i
did keep up with it for a while
uh batman versus robin was absolute
trash it was so bad uh very late to the
party hi all well
john actually you're so late that it's
uh it's about to wrap up
for the evening had to scroll back
through the video because of technical
issues
uh but i hit the m cross-eyed face
i can honestly say i choked
[Laughter]
that hmm
that that that amused me thank you very
much for that
um you need to watch superman man of
tomorrow
um no
don't know that one haven't gotten that
one um
best superman one of the ones i've seen
is still superman versus the elite
i think ms wiger wolf is looking through
reviews of stuff you hated to bring them
up again yeah i think so too but the
thing is
that's a flawed strategy because if it's
something i've already done a review on
the bulk of what i'm going to say is i
did a review already look it up
do you consider yourself hot or sexy on
a good day i do
standard day-to-day
50 50.
about half the time i think i look good
about the other half i'm like oh
because despite my ego
which is nothing to sneeze at
it's uh it's quite an ego
yeah i know it's still about half the
time maybe
what's your opinion on the snyder
cutting are you looking forward to it i
won't have an opinion till i see it and
am i looking forward to it
sort of
[Music]
i'm kind of looking looking forward to
finally seeing it
i'm not looking forward to doing a
review of it because i am
95 certain that i'm gonna say it's still
not a good movie
and i'm gonna have to deal with all the
snyder fans
coming at me for that so
is that water or granny's peach tea uh
it's water yeah
wtf was that movie yeah yeah very
seriously who's the best
best skeksis the chamberlain
[Music]
don't run away kell fling
hmm
he's so good
thoughts on be kind rewind have you seen
it i haven't seen it i know what it's
about
interesting premise not really my thing
i'm gonna wrap it up i see people are
starting to bow out and this is like my
third or fourth time saying i was gonna
wrap it up so
thank you very much all thank you for
joining me
thank you for helping me get to 50
000. this is uh
this is an insane benchmark and i
could not be happier or more touched
at having hit it so thank you so much
thank you for being here today thank you
for
every time you tune in every time you
watch
every time you like every time you
comment
thank you and remember
that
you are beautiful you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i just run the
meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
mccabe